[Aplausos]
patos gigantes de piscina inflables
estuvieron entre los manifestantes
tailandeses mientras miles de personas
se reunieron frente al cuartel general
de la policía en la capital bangkok y
ahora son como una mascota para la
protesta y una valoración para nosotros
los manifestantes salpicaron pintura un
día después de que docenas de personas
fueron heridas por gases lacrimógenos y
cañones de agua en la peor violencia en
meses de manifestaciones
antigubernamentales
los patos inflables aparecieron por
primera vez fuera del parlamento de este
martes cuando los manifestantes los
usaron como escudo para protegerse a los
patos inflables estaban destinados a
estar en el agua sólo para molestar a la
policía pero resultó que podemos usarlos
me da risa
sería sólo un juguete para niños y si la
policía no hubiera disparado cañones de
agua y gas lacrimógeno contra nosotros
no habría un escudo de pato que nos
salvará de la oms
en perpetua protesta contra el poder
desde julio los manifestantes dijeron
que su próximo evento tendrá lugar el 25
de noviembre en su punto de mira está la
administración de la fortuna del palacio
real que el monarca ha tomado bajo su
control personal el fondo está valorado
en decenas de miles de millones de
dólares